so i know that it has been announced
that you will be playing the leading
role of miss michelle obama for the
showtime series first ladies and i know
you spoke with the former first lady
and i just want to know was there any
advice or any
pointers that she gave you to prepare
for portraying her for the series
absolutely not and let me tell you
something i wish she had
because i could use that right now
michelle and she she really insists that
you call her michelle but
i i could use it right now but she's
she's
she's one of those she's she's
everything
yes she's she is a a goddess
i he probably would cringe if i said
that but
i'm gonna say it anyway i love her
beyond love
and i think she would never do
what you suggested because she has too
much respect
for people um in whatever field
they they study she's just all she's
just a bastion of support
that's what she is viola davis how to
get away with murder
thank you pete nowak shonda rhimes the
beautiful cast of how to get away with
murder it's been
it was the joy and journey of my life
to go on this ride with you i can't
mention all your names but you know i
love you
love you love you but shonda rhimes
thank you
pete no work for redefining what it
means to be a leading lady what it means
to be a woman what it means to be black
on network television thank you for the
ride of my life
thank you naacp so viola you've always
been
just such a source of inspiration for
our community whether on screen
or on social media with your inspiring
words and celebration of our culture
what are some ways that you would
encourage young creators who are now
coming up to step
into hone and really maximize their
artistic and creative power
especially as we continue to navigate
the kobe 19 pandemic
um you know i always say that
whatever field that you decide to pursue
in the entertainment field whether it be
acting whether it be music or writing or
whatever
you have to do it as much as you can
in as many scenarios as you can you do
it
until you just you just sort of spread
um a wealth of of your work
around um because i i feel
i feel like i have to say that because i
think that
a lot of people who even come in to go
come into acting
have a tendency to want to be a famous
actor not just an
actor so i encourage young people to
really really hone their skills
be as excellent as you possibly can
always challenge yourself um work in
every capacity
you can not just in hollywood in schools
in your community um you spread a wealth
of your talent everywhere
because your responsibility is just to
plant the seed
you don't know how it's going to grow
you just have to plant it and
that's what i would say you recently
made history as the most nominated black
actress in oscar history you won two
awards tonight
you've talked about viewing award season
as a platform
and quote another opportunity to speak
about the fundamental truths of
hollywood and this business
and america so what do you think of the
fact that this award show
is one of the few that celebrates and
honors black talent in the way
that they should be what does that say
about hollywood
and america well what it says about well
what it says about the end of double acp
image awards is thank god
for the naacp image awards or else we
would still stay in the cloak of
invisibility
um what i will say about
hollywood is the same thing i say about
black history
that actors and artists of color
we are artists we belong in the same
conversation
as everyone else and be
it it's because uh a lot of times we are
forgotten or not held in as much esteem
as sometimes our white counterparts is
why we need
naacp image awards is why we need
essence luncheon and we literally look
i don't know if i could say i look
forward to the day where there is no
naacp image awards or whatever because
and listen it's we're dope
right but i look forward to the
day when we no longer have to teach
people how to see us
we no longer have to keep you know
trying to break
out of that shroud of invisibility but
we
our talent can be embraced as much as
our
white counterparts i look forward to
that day
but i feel i really do feel
that the game changers the rule breakers
the people who are gonna change the
narratives of the narrative out there
is us that's who's gonna be
who's gonna change it we are now
harnessing all of our talent
all of our um ingenuity and
we are literally demanding to be seen
i first wanted to say you know you
played both characters of um
how to get away with murder and also
uh marine and they were both very
outspoken
and you know very complex so which
of the you know both characters were
more emotional for you to play or
how or which one did you relate to uh
the most
i relate to both of them they both i
relate to both of them
i relate to any human being that's
trying to navigate
their way in the world and they're not
understood
uh people refuse to see them they're
both they're two dark-skinned black
women
um which that's a whole other
conversation
in terms of colorism right there they're
all smart
they're both smart they're talented
they're forced to be reckoned with
and yet nobody sees it they're
constantly having to prove themselves um
i get that that has been my life so
i and i think it's very honest
so um i relate i i relate to to
both of my i have to say that at 55
the only thing that has changed is
i refuse to explain myself now
that's the only thing that's probably
changed but still
i feel that what comes at me is still
a lot of the energy that came at my
rainy and annalise keating
you